[موسيقى]
جددت اسرائيل غاراتها على قطاع غزه
بالتزامن مع عمليات توغل محدوده لجيش
الاحتلال من جهتها تواعدت حماس بالرد اما
نتنياهو فاكد انه لن يصمت ازاء اطلاق
الصواريخ من
[موسيقى]
غزه
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش من زاويتين اي
رساله تريد اسرائيل ايصالها جراء هذا
التصعيد العسكري ومن المعني
باستلامها ومدى احتمالات تطور الغارات
المتقطعه الحاليه الى عدوان شامل على مدن
القطاع السلام
عليكم تعرض قطاع غزه في الفتره الاخيره
لسلسله هجمات اسرائيليه هجمات لا يمكن
للمراقب ان يتجاهل ربطها بمجموعه تطورات
سياسيه فاسرائيل على اعتاب انتخابات مبكره
ومصر كما يراها الاسرائيليون لم تحقق بعد
نتائج من العمليه العسكريه ضد الجماعات
المسلحه في سينا كذلك الموقف في سوريا وما
يمكن ان ينتج عنه في اي لحظه امر يغ يشغل
بال الاسرائيليين كما ان زياره امير قطر
الشيخ حمد خليفه الثاني الى قطاع غزه
الثلاثاء كاول زياره لزعيم عربي للقطاع
المحاصر تاتي هي الاخرى لتضيف لتضيف عفوا
بعدا جديدا لابعاد اقليميه متشابكه تحيط
بغزه حلقه جديده من حلقات التصعيد
الاسرائيلي ضد قطاع غزه شهداء وجرحى في
غارات اسرائيليه استهدفت مجموعات من
المقاومه الفلسطينيه بالتزامن مع توغل مح
ح دود في شمال بلده بيت حنون في شمال
القطاع تصعيد يدل على سياسه اسرائيل التي
لا تتبدل ولا تتغير في التعامل مع غزه
بالابقاء على الوضع بلا تصعيد مفتوح ولا
تهدئه مستمره في ذات الوقت مستخدمه في ذلك
ذرائع اطلاق الصواريخ الله اكبر اضافه الى
ذلك فان التوقعات بالتصعيد حاضره دوما مع
قرب اجراء اي انتخابات اسرائيليه كما هو
عليه الوضع حاليا بعد اعلان نتنياهو عن
اجراء انتخابات مبكره في كانون الثاني
يناير القادم حيث عهد الفلسطينيون لعب
المرشحين الاسرائيليين على وتر الامن
لاقناع
ناخبيهم في جوله التصعيد هذه كان احد
الشهداء قياديا ميدانيا في كتائب القسام
الذراع العسكري لحركه حماس التي اكدت ان
هذه الغارات لن تمر دون حساب لكن كثيرين
يرون ان هذه الجوله من التصعيد ستبقى في
في اطارها المحدود ولن تتصاعد برغبه
فلسطينيه لاعتبارين مهمين الاول التزام
بالدور المصري الساعي دوما للحفاظ على
التهدئه خاصه مع تحسن العلاقات بين قطاع
غزه ومصر بعد الثوره وتعويل الفلسطينيين
على خطوات مصريه جاده لكسر الحصار والضغط
على اسرائيل بعدم شن اي حرب جديده على
القطاع ثانيا وربما هو الاعتبار الاهم في
الوقت الراهن هو ان الفصائل المختلفه
وتحديدا حماس ستنحل الى ضبط نفسها وعدم
منح اسرائيل اي فرصه للتاثير في زياره
امير قطر الذي ينتظر ان يصل غزه الثلاثاء
لاطلاق مشاريع اعاده الاعمار في القطاع في
زياره هي الاولى لزعيم عربي لغزه منذ فرض
الحصار عليها قبل ست
سنوات للمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا في هذه
الحلقه من غزه خيبر ابو سعده استاذ العلوم
السياسيه في جامعه الازهر من القدس
الدكتور مهدي عبد الهادي رئيس الاكاديميه
الفلسطينيه للشؤون الدوليه في القدس ومن
القاهره اللواء عادل سليمان مدير المركز
الدولي للدراسات المستقبليه والاستراتيجيه
اهلا بضيوفنا الثلاثه نبدا من غزه والسيد
ابو سعده برايك ما الذي ارادت اسرائيل
تحقيقه من خلال هذه الهجمات والغارات على
القطاع
يعني بدايه دعني اقول بانه الاعمال
الحربيه الاسرائيليه والتصعيد الاخير اصبح
امرا روتينيا لا يكاد يخلو يوما او اسبوعا
الا وتقوم به قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
بعمليات اغتيال او عمليات اقتحام لمناطق
قريبه من السياج الحدودي يبدو ان هذا
التصرف العسكري الاسرائيلي ياتي في سياق
كما تقول اسرائيل الحفاظ على قدرات الر
ردع الاسرائيليه خاصه بعد تنامي قوه
المقاومه الفلسطينيه في الفتره الاخيره
وحصولها على اسلحه اكثر قوه ثانيا
بالتاكيد هذا التصعيد الاسرائيلي يت يعني
ياتي في سياق حمله انتخابيه او انتخابات
مبكره في اسرائيل ستعقد في الثاني من شهر
يناير من العام القادم وبالتالي دائما
عودتنا اسرائيل على ان يكون هناك منافسه
حزبيه ويكون ضحيه هذه المنافسه الشعب
الفلسطيني وخاصه سكان غزه المحاصرين منذ
اكثر من خمس سنوات ويمكن ان نقول بانه
ثالثا هذا التصعيد يتزامن مع زياره الامير
القطري الى غزه ويبدو ان اسرائيل تحاول
مسبقا افشال هذه الزياره وافشال اي نتائج
ايجابيه قد تنتج عن زياره الامير القطري
التي لها علاقه باعاده الاعمار وكذلك من
الممكن ان ان تعطي مزيدا من الشرعيه لحركه
حماس في الشارع العربي والاسلامي اذا
حاولنا ان
نفكك خطوه خطوه هذه الاشارات التي ذكرتها
دكتور مهدي عبد الهادي البعد الانتخابي في
هذه الغارات هل تراه
كبيرا طبعا ما في شك اطلاقا الملف الداخلي
الاسرائيلي هو اساس التحرك الاسرائيلي
بالدرجه الاولى ليس فقط تصريحات نتنياهو
وليس فقط محاولات ب في تحريك العسكر
باستمرار مناخ الحرب المفروض على غزه هو
مناخ اسرائيلي بمعنى الرسائل الاسرائيليه
الداخليه تقول اسرائيل قوه لا تقهر لا
يوجد جيش اطلاقا يستطيع الان في المنطقه
العربيه هزم او اسقاط الجيش الاسرائيلي
والدرجه الثانيه ممكن اسقاط اي نظام عربي
في مليونيه في ميدان التحرير ومن هذا
المدخل المفهوم الامني الاسرائيلي بالدرجه
الاولى يوظف انتخابيا في هذه المرحله بان
نتنياهو قادر على لجم امن كامل بالضفه
الغربيه عزل كامل واسر للقدس واحتواء غزه
اي كينونه فلسطينيه تقام بغزه سوف تقام
بشروط اسرائيليه بمعنى لا يمكن تطوير
المؤسسه الامنيه الفلسطينيه بغزه لا يمكن
تطوير العلاقه المصريه الحمساويه في غزه
الا بموافقه اسرائيليه لا يمكن تفعيل
الحضور المصري بسناه الا بموافقه
اسرائيليه لا يمكن بناء اي شيء في غزه الا
بموافقه اسرائيل بمعنى اذا ما تبنيه اليوم
يمكن ه هو غدا وبالتالي لابد ان يؤخذ
الملف الاسرائيلي بالدرجه الاولى هو ملف
داخلي اسرائيلي بالدرجه الاولى الان نتحدث
عن غزه واقتحامات غزه بمعنى مناخ الحرب
المستمر حصار مستمر لغزه عزل كامل لغزه اي
تطور داخلي وايضا رساله للذين انتخبوا قبل
ايام ابو مرزوق لرئاسه
المكتب مكتب حماس او هنيه نائب له اي
كينون مكتب السياسي اي كينونه سياسيه في
غزه يجب ان تكون بالمفهوم الاسرائيلي كما
يطرح نتنياهو في الساحه الانتخابيه هي ضمن
الاطار الاسرائيلي وبالتالي يتحدث عن
الضفه الغربيه امن كامل بالضفه الغربيه
عزل كامل للقدس وفتح مكاتب الاداره
المدنيه بالضفه الغربيه ليتعاملوا مع
الفلسطينيين ويتعامل مع الامر الواقع صدق
اولا تصدق يوم امس كنا في عشاء مع الرئيس
كارتر في القدس وتحدثنا بتفصيل ابراهم بك
تحدث عن مفهوم الامن الاسرائيلي في الضفه
بانهم لن يخرجوا اطلاقا من الضفه الغربيه
حل الدولتين انتهى تعالوا نبحث عن كينونه
فلسطينيه في غزه على حساب ضم الضفه
الغربيه وانهاء المشروع الفطاني الفلسطيني
في في هذه النقطه تحديدا اللواء عادل
سليمان هذه العلاقه الاسرائيليه المصريه
الجديده هل يمكن ان تكون ايضا ما وجه لغزه
رساله ايضا للقياده المصريه
الجديده يعني انا اعتقد ان ما يجري على
الساحه ال الفلسطينيه في قطاع غزه هو مبني
على خطه ممنهجه وكانها روتين منتظم رساله
واضحه بان اسرائيل لن تسمح بان تكون غزه
قاعده للمقاومه العسكريه باي شكل من
الاشكال سواء من حركه حماس او من اي
منظمات او جماعات جهاديه اخرى اذا كان
هناك من يريد ان يتعامل مع اسرائيل فيما
يتعلق بقطاع غزه فيجب ان يكون التعامل على
اساس انهاء كل تفكير في دعم المقاومه
العسكريه المسلحه لان اسرائيل لن تسمح
بهذا هذه هي الرساله الاسرائيليه سواء
كانت لمصر او كانت لقطر في زياره امير قطر
المجمعه في غد ان قطاع غزه اما يكون قطاعا
مسالما ويلجا الى الحلول السلميه
والتفاوض ولا احد يفكر في دع دعم فكره
المقاومه المسلحه التي تنطلق من غزه
كقاعده لها اعتقد ان هذه هي الرساله التي
يريد العدو الاسرائيلي ان يوجهها لكافه
الاطراف سواء كانت لمصر او لقطر او
للفلسطينيين في حركه حماس او لاي جماعات
تحاول ان تنشا خارج حماس في قطاع غزه هذه
هي الرساله الواضحه وايضا هي رساله طمانه
للمجتمع الاسرائيلي الداخلي في وهو على
ابواب انتخابات ان العصا الامنيه
الاسرائيليه لازالت يقظه ولن
ا تكف عن استهداف اي جمعات او عناصر او
توجهات تحمل بذور المقاومه العسكريه اذا
انتهت قصه المقاومه العسكريه فاسرائيل قد
تكون مستعده للتفاهم مع باقي الموضوعات
سواء كان اعاده اعمار قطاع غزه او فتح
المعابر وانهاء الحصار وانا اعتقد هذه
رساله واضحه بالنسبه لزياره امير قطر
المجمعه التي تحمل عنوان اعاده اعمار قطاع
غزه على ذكر اعاده الاعمار تحديدا يعني
ربما يعني على ذكر اعاده الاعمار تحديدا
ربما زياره امير قطر الشهيره الى الضاحيه
الجنوبيه
في بيروت ثم
المساهمه في اعاده اعمار الجنوب وبعض
القرى الجنوب هل وهنا اسال السيد ابو سعده
هل اسرائيل ارادت ان تقول للامير القطري
بانك اذا اردت ان تاتي هنا لاعاده الاعمار
فل تخذ في الحسبان بان اسرائيل قادره
دائما على التدمير وان اسرائيل لابد ان
تؤخذ في الحسبان عندما تقوم بهذه
الزياره هو بالتاكيد واسرائيل عمليا ارسلت
هذه الرساله الى قطر من خلال رفضها دخول
اي مواد بناء الى قطاع غزه عبر المعابر
الاسرائيليه التي تربط قطاع غزه باسرائيل
قطر عفوا اسرائيل لا تريد لا اعاده اعمار
ولا اعاده بناء ل لقطاع غزه اسرائيل تريد
ان يبقى قطاع غزه محاصرا وان يبقى السكان
يعانوا من ال الفقر والبطاله وسوء الاوضاع
المعيشيه ايه لعله و عسى كما تعتقد
اسرائيل ان ذلك يضعف من شعبيه حركه حماس
في قطاع غزه او في الشارع الفلسطيني بشكل
عام على ايه حال يعني حتى هذا الرفض
الاسرائيلي ايه يعني تم مقابلته بقبول
ايجابي مصري بان مواد البناء سوف تدخل عبر
ميناء ع عبر ميناء رفح او معبر رفح الواصل
بين قطاع غزه ومصر ولكن دائما اسرائيل هي
لاعب اساسي في الشان الفلسطيني سواء من
خلال تحكمها في المعا الفلسطينيه بين قطاع
غزه واسرائيل او من خلال محاولاتها
الدائمه لافشال اي تحرك فلسطيني سواء كان
تحرك سياسي او تحرك على المستويات الدوليه
اسرائيل دائما معنيه بتقديم القضيه
الفلسطينيه معنيه بتقديم قضيه الشعب
الفلسطيني حتى دائما تجد المبررات لان
تتهرب من اي مسؤوليات سياسيه تجاه الشعب
الفلسطيني حسب قرارات الشرعيه الدوليه
وفيما يتعلق بال بال ما قالته اسرائيل من
ان هناك صواريخ اطلقت من قطاع غزه دكتور
مهدي عبد الهادي ليس سرا بان حركه حماس
طوال الاشهر وحتى السنوات الماضيه ارادت
ان تكون هي المتحكمه في موضوع اطلاق
الصواريخ وان لا تترك العمليه خارج
سيطرتها حتى ان البعض اتهمها بانها في
النهايه لا تختلف عن السلطه هل تعتقد بان
البعض ربما في قطاع غزه وارتباط بالوضع
السوري اراد ان يفجر الموقف
في غزه واستدراج اسرائيل ربما لتصعيد لم
تكن هي بالضروره ترغب
فيه يعني نن خلينا نرجع للاساسيات
بالاساسيات هنالك ازمه قياده في غزه كما
هي ازمه قياده بالضفه ازمه قياده فلسطينيه
وازمه رؤيه فلسطينيه الاخوان في غزه بعد
هذا الانفصال لمده خمس سنوات لحتى الان ست
سنوات حتى الان هذا النزيف الصال الحقيقي
بين الفلسطينيين جعل الاخوه بغزه يباشروا
ويبادر الى خلق هذه الكينونه نظام امني
نظام سياسي نظام حزبي مؤسسات فعاليات
تواصل مع الساحه العربيه والاقليميه مع
تركيا ومع ايران وتطور هذا هذه الكينونيا
داخل هذه المؤسسه الان السؤال للاخوان
بغزه كل الاخوان بغزه ان كانوا حماس او
غير حماس ما مستقبل قطاع غزه بعيدا عن
البيت الفلسطيني الان في اعمار الكل مع
الاعمار لانه هذه الزياره لن ترسخ
الانفصال او لن ترسخ الانقسام لانه
السعوديه بنات والامم المتحده بنات وال ان
دي بي بنات والاعمار مطلوب ومنح ولحياه
الناس اسرائيل الان تتدخل بالملف الداخلي
في قطاع غزه لتقول للكل بلا استثناء
اضمنوا لي امن ما بدي عنف انا ما عندي
مانع اي كينونه فلسطينيه بتبن وها اخوان
المسلمين مع حماس حماس مع ايران حماس مع
تركيا حماس مع قطر ما عندي مشكله مادام
انا عندي امن كامل بقطاع غزه ومادام انا
متمتعه باسر لت وتهويد القدس والاقصى
بالتحديد ومادام الضفه الغربيه اصبحت نظام
اي محصور في في كانتونات ثلاثه اربع نابس
والخليل ورام الله وقادر على هذا الامن
اسرائيل تستطيع ان تتعايش مع هذا الامر
السؤال الملح الان علينا كلنا يا معشر
الفلسطينيين الى متى نقبل الامر الواقع
كما هو والى متى نرسخ هذه الحاله
بعلاقاتنا الاقليميه والدوليه في صراع
صراعات داخليه داخليه في غزه الان في
صراعات صراعات مع السلفيه الصوفيه صراعات
مع الجهاديه صراع حماس داخل حماس صراع
الاحزاب صراع الانتخابات يعني الناس لم
تكبر الى
فلسطينيتين اولا الفصيل جاء اولا هذه
الازمه اللي شاهدناها الان بالضفه الغربيه
في انتخابات البلديات سقوط فتح
وا سقوط كل الاقنعه عن الناس المساله الان
مساله فلسطينيه صحيح اسرائيل لن تنسحب من
الضفه صحيح اسرائيل مرتاحه بالامر الواقع
اسرائيل ست تجير الملف الغزاوي الى مصر
ازمه امنيه مصريه باستمرار وتستنزف
العلاقات مع مصر من هذا التوجه وايضا
علاقاتها العربيه تفضلوا يا اخواننا العرب
بنوا وعمرو اضمنوا لنا الامن اولا ونحن ما
عندنا مانع هذه الرؤيه الاسرائيليه
والتمتع السؤال للفلسطينيين اين انتم يا
قاده فلسطينيين يا قاده المستقبل من هذا
الحاله ال اللي بت تقطع الانسان يوميا لما
بتشوف الاقصى يسرل ويهود ويقتحم يوميا
وانت عم تتحدث الان على انتخابات وبتتحط
على بناء بيت وتتحدث على فتح المعابر
وتتحدث على كينونه فلسطينيه مستقله عن
المستقبل كقضيه فلسطينيه ارض وشعب وحقوق
ولهذا ايضا ولهذا ربما جزء جزء ايضا من
نعم يعني بعد اذنك ربما ايضا هذا جزء من
من هذه التساؤلات المشروع تحنا الى
الموضوع الذي سنتطرق اليه بعد الفاصل وهو
الى اي مدى ما جرى مؤخرا في غزه قد يتطور
لاحقا الى اكثر من مجرد غارات او هجمات
الى ربما شيء مفتوح من العمل العسكري ضد
غزه نتطرق الى هذه النقطه بعد فاصل قصير
نرجو ان تبقوا
[موسيقى]
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد ما زلتم معنا في
هذه الحلقه التي نتناول فيها الهجمات
الاسرائ الاخيره على قطاع غزه دلالاتها
السياسيه واحتمالات تطورها الى ما هو اكثر
من ذلك اللواء عادل سليمان في القاهره هل
تعتقد بان هذه الهجمات يمكن ان تصبح في
سياق ما عمل عسكري اسرائيلي متواصل على
القطاع يعني انا استبعد هذا الاحتمال
لان البيئه الامنيه عموما في المنطقه ما
يجري على الساحه السوريه ما حدث خرا في
لبنان الموقف التركي مما يجري الموقف
الايراني مما يجري الموقف ايضا في مصر
والعمليات الجاريه في سيناء كل هذا يجعل
من المستبعد ان تطور اسرائيل عملياتها في
قطاع غزه لانني اعتقد انها ليست في حاجه
الى تطوير العمليات بهذا الشكل لا يوجد ما
يهدد امنها بدرجه تدفعها الى مثل هذا التط
وور الذي قد يؤدي الى نوع من
الاصطفاف المفتقد الان على الساحه العربيه
وهي بالقطع لا تريد ان يحدث مثل هذا
الاصطفاف والتوحد ضد موقف قد تقوم به
اسرائيل في عمليات شامله ضد قطاع غزه هو
يكفيها هذه العمليات النوعيه الانتقائيه
برسائلها التي تصل على الفور الى الجهات
المعنيه
لا ليس هناك ما يدعو لان ولكن ولكن حضره
الل يعني يعني لما لماذا نستبعد ان
اسرائيل لا تريد ان توجه
لمصر رسالات تخويف او حتى القول بان في
النهايه مصر مرسي لا تختلف عن عن مرسي عن
عن عن مصر مبارك فيما يتعلق بالوقوف
السلبي تجاه ما يجري في في في غزه هل هل
لها مصلحه في ان تظهر النظام الجديد في
مصر بهذا
الشكل يعني انا لا اعتقد ان مجرد هذا زده
مصر ليست في حاجه حقيقه الامر الحاله
المصريه حاليا ليست في حاجه لمثل هذه
الرسائل مصر اعلنت على على لسانها الرسمي
انها مع الاتفاقيات ومعاهده السلام
القائمه والسفير المصري الجديد كان يقدم
اوراق اعتماده منذ بضعه ايام في اسرائيل
مصر ليست في في حاجه الى مثل هذه الرسائل
الان وهذه الرسائل هي واصله لمصر طبيعي
ولا تحتاج لتكلفه اعلى دائما العمليات
الشامله تكلفه وهذه التكلفه لابد ان يكون
لها مقابل ا واعتقد ان مثل هذه العمليات
الشامله ليست لها مقابل واسرائيل تستطيع
ان تحقق هذا المقابل دون اللجوء الى هذه
العمليات التي قد تقلق ضدها تيارا معاديا
وتوحده هي ليست في حاجه اليه هي ليست في
حاجه الى ذلك ولكن بالنسبه للوضع في في
غزه سيد مخيمر ابو سعده هل تعتقد بان
اهالي غزه لا يستبعدون ان تمضي الامور
اكثر مما وصلت اليه لحد
الان و بصراحه نحن دائما نتوقع الاسوا من
اسرائيل
ودائما قبل الانتخابات الاسرائيليه يمكن
ان تحدث مفاجات ويمكن ان يحدث تصعيد
اسرائيلي اكثر خطوره مما يحدث الان ويمكن
ان يكون عمليه رصاص مصبوب رقم اثنين كما
حذرت كثير من الصحف والمواقع الاعلاميه
الاسرائيليه ولكن انا تقديري في نهايه
الامر اسرائيل لا تريد الذهاب الى نقطه
اضعاف حماس او الى نقطه التخلص من حركه
حماس في قطاع غزه اسرايل اسرايل تعلم
تماما بان الحدود بين غزه واسرائيل شهدت
هدوءا غير مسبوقا خلال ال الثلاث سنوات او
الاربع سنوات الاخيره منذ حرب غزه وهي
تعلم ان اي اضعاف لحركه حماس سوف يؤدي الى
تقويه الحركه الجهاديه السلفيه في فلسطين
او تقويه تيار او حركه الجهاد الاسلامي
وبالتالي تصبح الامور معقده اكثر مما هي
الان هو في نهايه الامر اسرائيل تريد ان
تبقي قطاع غزه تحت الضغط وتحت الضربات هي
تقول بانه على الرغم من حاله الهدوء
والاستقرار هي تريد هدوء اكثر من هذا
الهدوء والاستقرار الموجود حاليا تريد ان
تضغط على حركه حماس وحكومتها في غزه لضبط
الحدود وضبط اطلاق الصواريخ ولكن في نهايه
الامر استبعد تماما ان تقدم اسرائيل على
خطوه اعاده احتلال قطاع غزه لان هذا مكلف
عسكريا وماليا ولا تريد كما قلت الذهاب
الى نقطه اضعاف حركه حماس لان البدائل سوف
تكون اكثر سوءا على اسرائيل وعلى المنطقه
وبتالي لكن هل هل هل ربما هل هل اسرائيل
في وارد وهنا نختم الحلقه مع الدكتور مهدي
عبد الهادي باختصار لو تكرمت هل في وارد
الحسابات الاسرائيليه ان تكون المساله
ابعد واقوى من مجر من مجرد ما حدث لحد
الان طبعا طبعا القضيه هي اوسع من ذلك
كثيرا اسرائيل تنظر الى الاقليم تنظر الان
الى المناورات العسكريه لاول مره مصريه
تركيه تنظر لاول مره دور النيتو مع
الاتراك في التدريبات العسكريه تنظر لاول
مره تراجع واشنطن عن دعم اسرائيل في عمليه
ايران وبالتحديد حديث واشنطن عن حوار مع
الايرانيين الان تصدمه لاسرائيل اسرائيل
تستعمل غزه الان كورقه ضاغطه اقليميه
لتقول لكل الاقليم ان انا قادره على ان
اضرب على ان اصفي على ان اتدخل وقدرتي
العسكريه الان موجوده ولا تستطيعون لجمي ت
يستعمل الفلسطيني تستعمل غزه كساحه
تدريبيه علنيه اعلاميه لاسرائيل لترد على
التنسيق الامني الان اللي بم الان او
المناورات بين مصر وتركيا لاول مره بال
السحه حديث مرسي عن هلال اسلامي يجمع
السعوديه وتركيا ومصر وايران اذا اذا تخلت
ايران عن بشار الاسد الحديث عن الاسلام
السياسي في صياغته القادمه اسرائيل تقول
الان بضرب غزه باغتيال سياسيه قادمه في ضد
قاده في غزه بوضع غزه في مناخ الحرب
باستمرار ورسائل لا تعمر الا باذني ولا
تتدخل الا بموافقتي تقول لهذه الساحه
العربيه الان باليقظه العربيه الحاليه انا
موجوده عليكم ان تاخذوني بالحساب والا
ساستمر بما انا علي شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور
مهدي عبد الهادي رئيس الاكاديميه
الفلسطينيه للشؤون الدوليه في القدس كنت
معنا من القدس شكرا ايضا لضيفنا من غزه
مخيمر ابو سعده استاذ العلوم السياسيه في
جماعه الازهر ومن القاهره اللواء عادل
سليمان مدير المركز الدولي للدراسات
المستقبليه والاستراتيجيه بهذا نصل
مشاهدينا الكرام الى نهايه هذه الحلقه من
برنامج ما وراء الخبر دمتم في رعايه الله
والى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء
ل